the democratic presidential race takes a
huge leap forward today because it is
super tuesday former vice president joe
biden starts the day with a big boost
last night three former rivals pete
buddha judge amy klobuchar
and beto o'rourke endorsed him last
night biden is trying to make this a
two-person race against senator bernie
sanders and voters will decide
in 14 states including texas and
california and one u.s territory
more than 1300 delegates will be awarded
today that is more than one-third of the
overall total at o'keefe is at a voting
place in arlington virginia another
state on the map today
ed good morning so why are these
endorsements so significant
hey tony good morning we're here at a
high school where there's already been a
steady stream of voters
those endorsements are a signal that at
least some moderate democrats are now
beginning to coalesce around biden
who's hoping that they give him a big
boost as he tries to surpass the current
front-runner
vermont senator bernie sanders we are
better than this president
and so get up let's take back this
country
former vice president joe biden is
riding into super tuesday on a fresh
wave of support
i'm delighted to endorse and support joe
biden for president
[Applause]
three of his former rivals pete
butterjudge amy klobuchar and beto
o'rourke
made last minute endorsements before
today's critical votes
if you are tired of the extremes you
have a home
with me and i think you know you have a
home
with joe biden they all argued that
biden has the best shot at defeating
president trump
we have someone who in fact is the
antithesis
of donald trump at a dueling rally
senator bernie sanders spoke
in minnesota senator klobuchar's home
state where he extended an olive branch
to all of amy and pete's millions of
supporters
the door is open come on in
but also acknowledged the moves to stop
him it's not just
the corporate establishment that's
getting nervous
the political establishment is getting
nervous
but this is not a two-man race sanders
and biden still face three other
opponents this super tuesday
massachusetts senator elizabeth warren
has failed so far to win a state
but is vowing to stay in the race we're
looking forward to gaining as many
delegates as
we can tomorrow especially from the
great state of california
and today we'll find out if former new
york mayor michael bloomberg's
unorthodox approach of focusing first on
super tuesday states
and spending more than 500 million
dollars will pay off
i'm in it to win it and
we are going to go out and we're going
to go get them
well well an estimated 15 million people
are expected to vote in super tuesday
states today and while those
endorsements
may give a boost to biden may cause some
voters to change their minds remember
many have already voted take for example
the three and a half million people
who cast early ballots in california
gail
they got no chance to change their mind
now i know
thank you very much ed